okay now this is really interesting okay
because I'm really enjoying this thing
that people think through I actually
particularly enjoy it don't take this
the wrong way it's not that I'm sadistic
or anything but I really enjoy it when
people are trying to think it through it
and it's not quite right here's why okay
it's not cuz I'm like haha you plebs you
know I remember when I because actually
this is a really important purchase to
go through because you can you can
crunch equations but still not get it
right and that's that's actually a
really bad position I mean you gotta
start somewhere
right but we want to push past that and
get out okay what does it mean when you
say it's auditive or it's always
positive or it's it can be negative but
only a little bit what does that mean so
let me try and pull through now some
people said to me okay
the initial velocity is negative okay
and I they've also shared the
acceleration not just the initial
acceleration but all acceleration is um
this is negative this is positive right
so since I'm positive then I should
always be accelerating are we going in
the same direction right and so I'm
always going to be negative well yes
that is no in this case it is but just
saying those two facts that this is
negative and this is positive
actually I robust right because positive
and negative doesn't mean see this is
the thing about acceleration and
deceleration right that the divisions in
the decelerating is it's always going to
be slowing down okay but the question is
why right it actually could turn the
object around and make it accelerate in
the positive direction in which case
this would not be true and they could
take positive values okay so how do we
go no I said
I said I'll show you three ways okay so
he's gonna go
which one should I show you first I'll
show you I'll show you this one okay now
how long did you feel like I'm a broken
record and I said when you trying to
solve something okay and especially when
it's confusing if there's any way all
that you can visualize something you
should do it okay and so I mean my first
is that was take this this is X with
respect to time let's graph this it's
not even that complicated of a graph
okay now think about this what you've
got is at time zero you start here and x
equals 1 okay
and I'm heading in with a negative
Direction some pay back down toward the
origin but how can I work out what's
going on here well have a look at this
function okay what happens as T
approaches infinity as T you know as as
time passes right this denominator is
gonna skyrocket inside it's gonna get
really huge right which means that of
the whole fraction if the denominator is
getting big if the whole thing is
getting very very small it's a pretty
zero right so I'm gonna get some
asymptotic behavior now I just kind of
conveniently filled it that's always
going down okay so I'm actually
suggesting it's monotonically decreasing
but how would I know that
okay number one if you actually do plots
and points right if you know nothing
about calculus you know you're a kid can
take this function put some values in
and you'll see the shape of it okay so
number one there's a visual proof okay
graph X and say from the graph you can
see it's never actually there good 20
points okay so it's the velocity is
always negative it's toward the it's
downward direction okay so this proof
number one number two is you guys know
calculus okay you have worked out the
whole C function right and the velocity
function what was it
and this is in terms of X we had in
terms of time as well is it a week did
no I'm kidding you never saw that
we had the velocity function in terms of
X but actually want to know not just how
its behaving in terms of where it is the
house behaving as time progresses okay
so if that's my displacement function
I'm just gonna write it with a negative
infantry next to make it easier to
differentiate okay differentiate this is
just chain rule okay so what I do first
- - right let's bring it around the
front so I'm gonna get - four okay and
then I'm gonna reduce the power by one
so that's going to be to the minus three
that was the outside I should
differentiate the inside as well right
but the inside just turns out to me what
okay so that's that so I got this okay
now there's two things to note about
this number one what was I saying our
stationary points before but they don't
exist for 20 points
okay you know they can't exist because V
like there's no value of T that you can
put into this velocity function they
don't make the whole thing zero nothing
you can put in there to make it stop
okay because no matter how big your
values of T will get this thing will
still be a small negative value okay and
just wonder how can we actually prove
that rigorously well you start with this
think back to your inner qualities okay
you thought they were this we're talking
that's it tuns iron actually it's
important for things like motion if we
establish that te ice ax granite
original is zero okay that means if you
hadn't rooted this right and the s'mores
it can get is zero right well then if I
add a positive value to it it must be
positive you're happy with that so I've
lost that equality sign okay now if you
take a positive number and you cube it
it will still be positive so not G Plus
that means positive okay now
multiplication and division they work
much the same in terms of the sign or
something right so if I stock of minus
four on the edge of mind this thing is
change the inequality because I've
multiplied by negative number right so
there's my velocity it's always negative
okay which is as required yeah one
method was by graphing X okay I'm just
arguing visually second method was by
going to a little more calculus getting
here in terms of T and mu 300 equality
the Fed Minh that is the trickiest one
okay but it's kind of the coolest it's
the most elegant one I have a think
about what do I want what my
acceleration function okay and I want my
velocity function yeah now in order for
it to go from an initial negative to
turn around and and violaceous and
country don't become positive okay I'm
going to go from negative to positive
that means I've got a pass zero right
that's in between negative positive so
I'm gonna get this somehow and go
through it but V equals zero is there a
point according to these equations right
where the velocity is zero forget the
fact that we can approve that it could
never be let's just imagine that it got
to that point where is the point where
the velocity is U we could be credited
it's at the origin right you stick zero
to your left hand side divided by two x
cubed equals zero that's zero so if you
work in velocity zero the only place
that can happen is that the arm okay but
he's the kick on right and he is where
I'm trying to get you to understand what
are these equations mean at the origin
not only is your velocity zero okay but
also your acceleration zero you should
put it in right so your velocity zero
acceleration is you hurt you can't move
there's nothing acting on you
make you stop baby okay I've just stuck
at the origin and there's nothing that
can actually put you off there okay so
we just shown that you can never
actually get to the origin invoice in
Canterbury quizzer but if you somehow
break the laws of physics and arrive at
the origins yeah yeah school my bus easy
right not even positive values of me the
universe might sit back and says guess
what here you're gonna stuck here
forever you got zero velocity zero
acceleration you stop we can actually
never go positive okay so three
approaches they're all equally valid the
important thing is that you get how
these equations mean something and you
can see that simply machining out
numbers and try different shara and see
where you go from there is inadequate
you're really gonna have the brain
switch and these